i find that i have a battle within  myself  of being overly critical and then  having to walk myself through that and  go like hey  dude shut up it's okay i get that  that's kind of miserable do you have any  tricks for dealing with that  i try very hard to find something  that even my meanest most  self-effacing judgmental version of  myself  can accept as being at least  decent and i take that and i build on it  and i try to make a foundation of like  you're not a piece of [ __ ] that's my  foundation and from that i can find my  way like a ladder  clinging to little bits of like  positivity  to like feeling good about myself it  does take work though it's not something  i find  innately i'm incredibly jealous of  confident people